elle sera créée début 2013 alors la
banque publique d'investissement et bien
va fusionner oseo et le fsi le fonds
stratégique d'investissement
son objectif est bien et de financer les
pme prometteuses et pour ceux là et bien
là bpi bénéficiera d'une force de frappe
de 42 milliards d'euros tout de suite
donc sans plus tarder l'audition de
jean-pierre juillet très bonne matinée a
tous bien mes chers collègues en sachant
que certains ont des impératifs horaires
apparemment les feuilleton continue donc
nous devrions libérer certains collègues
à à 11 heures oui c'est ça oui bon
monsieur le directeur général mes chers
collègues nous sommes heureux en tous
les cas d'accueillir ce matin monsieur
jean pierre jouyet directeur général de
la caisse des dépôts pour nous exposer
les grandes lignes la future banque
publique d'investissement sa gouvernance
et son rôle
vous êtes auditionné à la fois par la
commission des affaires économiques et
celles de développement durable je
raccourcis aménagement du territoire etc
non mais nos deux commissions décidé de
prendre un avis sur le projet de loi
instaurant la banque publique
d'investissement en désignant d'ailleurs
respectivement notre collègue andré vers
eto'o pour la commission développement
durable
pardon bonjour jeune homme est notre
collègue martial bourquin pour ce qui
concerne la commission des affaires
économiques
donc ils seront les deux interlocuteurs
privilégiés après votre exposé monsieur
le directeur général la création de la
banque publique d'investissement
s'inscrit dans la politique du
gouvernement en faveur de la merde
l'amélioration de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises pour favoriser leur
développement notamment s'agissant des
entreprises du secteur industriel
vous vous doutez bien monsieur le
directeur général que le sénat
représentant d'après la constitution
j'insiste le les collectivités vous
serez pas étonné qu'ils aient des
questions concernant le rôle des
collectivités tout spécialement des
régions vis-à-vis à la fois de la
holding mais aussi des deux filiales que
qui sont présentés à savoir la bpi
financement innovation et la bpi
investissements et d'ailleurs vous
expliquerai comment ceux ci s'articule
avec en particulier les tpe les pme les
hôtes et i qui est l'interlocuteur et
entre financement innovation et bpi
investissements je suis persuadé que
vous les avez nous éclairer sur le rôle
de ces deux filiales de la holding
les rôles respectifs et aussi sur la
fusion d'un certain nombre d'opérateurs
à l'heure actuelle je pense effet si
bien sûr et cdc entreprises commencent
tout ceci se regroupent à la fois sur le
plan de l'efficacité des opérations mais
aussi sur le plan des ressources
humaines
votre intervention sur le directeur
général est d'autant plus importante que
les caisses des dépôts est déjà très
impliquée d'ailleurs dans le volet
investissement avec cdc entreprises et
le fond et le fsi est que dans la
branche aussi dans la branche
financement puisque vous êtes aussi
actionnaire d'oseo
donc ça remet un peu d'ordre dans
l'organigramme de tout ceci j'imagine
que c'est en tous les cas des objectifs
il est donc essentiel que la création de
cette nouvelle banque publique
d'investissement ne soit pas simple à
simple habillage de l'existant apporte
une véritable valeur ajoutée
je crois que ce sont vos explications ce
matin qui nous permettront de comprendre
effectivement d'abord la complexité
aussi des outils existants tous les cas
le ressenti par les entreprises à
l'heure actuelle en améliorant
particulier l'efficacité est peut-être
en changeant l'ordre de grandeur des
s'agissant de l'organigramme le futur
banque vous nous préciser préciserait
aussi s'il y a regroupés en deux
structures et avec quelles conséquences
voilà mon cher collègue de vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président je le
directeur général chers collègues donc
nous sommes également très intéressé par
tout ce qui va nous être dit car
évidemment cette banque comme l'indiqué
le président de république va donc
s'inscrire concrètement dans la feuille
de route de la transition écologique
elle va aussi par son rôle sur les
territoires influencer la politique
d'aménagement du territoire qui fait
partie de notre commission et donc nous
sommes nous aussi avide de savoir un
petit peu comment ces activités vont
s'articuler et comment vous allez donc
concrètement aujourd'hui répondre aux
attentes des entreprises et de tous les
acteurs économiques de notre pays
voilà donc je profite puisque tout
l'essentiel était dit par un daniel
raoul pour dire aux membres de la
commission du vent durable que nous nous
réunissons à 15h pour donc entendre le
rapporteur pour avis sur la mission de
développement durable dans notre salle
habituelle voilà merci monsieur le
directeur général vous avez la parole et
j'ai oublié de présenter je vous en prie
hier j merci beaucoup monsieur le
président raúl et éval messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur vers est aux cieux
plus rien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs alors je ne vais pas revenir
sur les orientations et les priorités
politiques que représente la banque
publique d'investissement puisque vous
l'avez fait vous l'avez parfaitement
indiqués
la france doit re d'ailleurs redynamiser
son tissu d'entreprises et la création
de la bpi incarne cette nouvelle
ambition le développement des
entreprises est au coeur des missions
que législateur a confié à la caisse des
dépôts et missions que nous souhaitons
maintenir et amplifier à travers la
banque publique d'investissement avec
monsieur monsieur gosset grainville qui
m'accompagne ce matin directeur général
adjoint et notre groupe est présent
depuis les années 1990 dans
l'investissement dans les pme et a
fortement amplifié ses actions depuis la
crise de 2008 sur la partie
investissement tout table tout d'abord à
travers le plan stratégique élan 2020 la
création du fsi en 2008 vous l'avez
rappelé le programme fsi france
investissement mars 2012 ya un
investissement sur deux dans les pme
aujourd'hui qui est financé grâce au
soutien du groupe caisse des dépôts sur
la partie financement ensuite la caisse
des dépôts est à l'actionnaire
historique d'oseo à hauteur de 27% et
les fonds des pagnes et leur principal
financeur la caisse des dépôts et donc
le partenaire naturel de l'état pour
créer et piloter ce nouvel outil et
s'apprête à investir environ la moitié
de ses fonds propres ce qui lui impose
d'intervenir dans le respect de ses
intérêts patrimoniaux et comme
protecteur de l' épargne des français
j'ajoute qu'à travers vous l'avez
souligné monsieur le président qu'à
travers la gouvernance propre à laquelle
se déposent c'est également la
représentation nationale qui aura un
poids particulier sur la banque publique
d'investissement puisque la
représentation nationale est présente à
la commission de surveillance de la
caisse des dépôts et consignations alors
la loi portant création de la bpi est un
acte fondateur qui ne détermine pas pour
autant l'ensemble du schéma une mission
de préfiguration été confiée à nicolas
dufourcq toutes les questions ne sont
pas résolues
il appartient aussi au parlement d'en
débattre c'est qu'il y aura
dans un débat à l'assemblée nationale et
comme je vous présente donc la vision
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui et au
sénat je sais mais je dois faire montrer
mon attachement bicaméralisme alors la
bpi sont d'abord des principes simples
et lisibles c'est un outil destiné à
accompagner le développement des
entreprises principalement des des pme
et des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire elle interviendra
finalement sous forme d'un de
financement d'investissements fonds
propres et le conseil aux entreprises et
de conseil notamment vous l'avez
souligné matière d'innovation un guichet
unique sera créé en région les régions
seront associés à la définition des
orientations et en ce qui concerne la
caisse des dépôts nous voyons qu'il y
ait des conseils d'orientation niveau
régional et qu'il y ait au niveau
régional des plateformes qui soient
créées à chaque fois qu'il ya des
initiatives ou des interventions
financières des régions ne pourront
faire des plates formes communes entre
la bpi et les régions à chaque fois
qu'il ya des financements commun de
projets entre la banque publique
d'investissement et les régions la
banque publique d'investissement sera
aussi la banque de la transition
énergétique
elle concentrera une part significative
de ses interventions sur la conversion
écologique de notre système productif et
là elle pourra s'appuyer sur les
activités existantes d'oseo déjà
positionnés sur des prêts verts vous
avez des prêts verts bonifiés ou des
prêts verts écoénergie ci concerne oseo
et sur les investissements dans le
domaine des éco énergie et des éco
industries du fsi et de cdc entreprises
donc cela fait partie de ce que vous
avez indiqué monsieur le président ce
terre qu'il y aura un regroupement en
fonction des thèmes et des orientations
la vie que ce soit l'innovation la
transition énergétique entre les
différents outils qui existent
aujourd'hui en termes d'investissements
ou en termes de financement ou en termes
de conseil aux entreprises puisque ce
sont les trois pôles de cette banque
publique d'investissement la la
bpi sera créée en regroupant des outils
existants pour mieux coordonner leurs
actions et leur donner plus d'efficacité
à sa création seront apportées aux éau
le fonds stratégique d'investissement et
cdc entreprises des apports
complémentaires dont la nature n'est pas
encore arrêtée renforceront son action
dans lesquels nos mii sociale et
solidaire dans tout ce qui est le
soutien à l'exportation
ce dernier domaine et en plus étranger à
la caisse des dépôts mais il peut
arriver qu'il y ait des prêts qu'ils
soient fait aussi à l'export ou pour
aider un certain nombre d'activités à
l'export et bien c'est financement
support de près par la suite seront
transférés à la banque publique
d'investissement puisque c'est à la
banque publique d'investissement qui
reviendra de faire ses actions de
soutien à l'exportation alors en termes
des moules de moyens d'intervention de
la bpi sera dotée des actifs aujourd'hui
porté par le fonds stratégique
d'investissement c'est à dire 15
milliards d'euros du fsi 25 milliards 2
0 ces actifs génère des résultats qui
permettront d' amplifier ses moyens
d'intervention
puisque par exemple l'augmentation du
capital non libéré du fsi qui est
aujourd'hui de 3,6 milliards d'euros
sera apportée à la banque publique
d'investissement complément de ce que
j'ai indiqué elle pourra également avoir
recours à l'endettement auprès des
banques sur les marchés ou auprès des
fonds des pagnes et un chiffre de 10
milliards d'euros qui a été évoqué grâce
au relèvement des livrets a et des
livrets de développement durable
le recours à l'endettement bien sûr
d'eux devra rester raisonnable en ce qui
concerne l' équilibre actionnarial et la
gouvernance
la bpi serait détenue à parité par un
épique et par la caisse des dépôts
l'état et la caisse des dépôts seront
représentés seront un strict équilibre
au conseil d'administration
et c'est un point auquel la caisse des
dépôts est extrêmement attaché
le président sera nommé sur proposition
de la caisse des dépôts est le directeur
général
par décret une proposition de loi
organique visant à soumettre la
nomination du président de
l'établissement public bpi group et de
directeur général de la hesse a b i
groupe à laval je crois des commissions
des finances a été déposé je moi je voi
tout à fait le signe positif de
l'exercice par le but par le parlement
de ses prérogatives à l'égard de cette
nouvelle entité
la gouvernance des filiales
d'investissement et de financement est
en cours de discussion la caisse des
dépôts souhaitent avoir une prééminence
sur la gouvernance de l'entité en charge
des investissements et des interventions
en termes de capital ce qui est là
effectivement dans le comme on dit dans
le journal de ce matin mission qui lui
est dévolue de par la loi et qui
constituent comme je les dis le coeur de
l'expertisé la caisse des dépôts et
surtout l'essentiel des apports en fonds
propres qui seront consentis par la
caisse des dépôts et consignations et la
bpi dans ce secteur comme dans l'eau
devra se comporter on avait un
investisseur avisé notamment à l'égard
des autorités de la concurrence est là
l'égard des autorités de la concurrence
communautaire notamment qui ne
manqueront pas de regarder ce dossier
avec le vigilance comme vous l'avez
souligné messieurs les présidents des
régions auront une place centrale dans
l'abbaye au niveau national elles seront
représentés au conseil d'administration
et présideront le comité national
d'orientation au niveau régional donc je
dédie le président les comités régionaux
d'orientation et éventuellement un camp
un comité d'engagement des plateformes
lorsqu'elles auront mutualiser des
moyens financiers substantiels en
complément de ceux de la banque publique
d'investissement alors pour la caisse
des dépôts
quels sont les points de vigilance
puisque la boum
j'interviens devant vous c'est de
toulouse adressée au directeur général
de la caisse
tout d'abord il y a des impacts sociaux
qui sont importants et auquel nous
serons entonne attentif avec monsieur
gosset grainville au cours des semaines
à venir puisque comme vous l'avez
compris si on transfère des activités on
va également transférer les personnels
dont il ya tout une question de statut
de mobilité des personnels de la caisse
des dépôts qu'elles nous devons être
extrêmement vigilants et qui vont
mobiliser et le directeur général de la
caisse directeur général adjoint et le
directeur général d'ing évidemment de la
bpi
deuxièmement l' équilibre entre l'état
et la caisse des dépôts dans la
gouvernance de la bpi qui sera
cristallisé dans un pacte d'actionnaires
nous demanderons que certaines décisions
du conseil d'administration requiert le
vote favorable des deux actionnaires
ce serait le cas de l'approbation du
budget la désignation des principaux
dirigeants
les investissements des investissements
majeurs les décisions sur le modèle
prudentielles en relation avec
l'autorité de contrôle prudentiel
l'allocation des ressources entre ceux
qui dépend du financement et ce qui
dépend de l'investissement plus
largement une fouille un bras de définir
l'articulation entre la gouvernance de
la bpi et de la caisse des dépôts et
notamment l'imbrication de la commission
de surveillance de la caisse des dépôts
dans l'administration ou l'orientation
c'est au parlement de le décider de la
banque publique d'investissement puisque
je le rappelle cette commission est
l'émanation du parlement donc quelque
part c'est la représentation du
parlement au sein de la bpi qui est qui
est en cause et sur cette question de la
gouvernance nous serons particulièrement
attentifs et g16 à ce que la part est la
parité actionnariale entre l'état et la
caisse des dépôts se reflète dans la
composition du conseil d'administration
c'est l'objet de l'article 3 du projet
de loi l'état et la caisse des dépôts
doivent disposer chacun d'autant
d'administrateurs au conseil 4 chacun le
directeur général de la bpi selon nous
doit être nommé par décret sur
proposition conjointe des deux
actionnaires vous
respectez ces équilibres troisièmement
le modèle prudentielles appliquées à
sept banques publiques sera soumis au
régime prudentiel dit de bâle
au delà du régime standard la quasi peau
demande à ce que des activités
d'investissement de la bpi soient
soumises aux contraintes prudentielles
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
parce que lorsque vous investissez en
capital par rapport à des
investissements en prêt vous devez
disposer de da en face de davantage de
fonds propres pour sécuriser vos un vélo
investissements à long terme et
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de bâle
nous avons des règles prudentielles
spécifique à la caisse des dépôts et sur
les interventions en capital par rapport
aux autres banques qui interviennent
elles davantage en prêt et donc nous
devons garder ses règles prudentielles
sur les investissements en capital de
toute façon quand bien même on
souhaiterait que ce soit différent les
autorités prudentielles nous le
rappellerai de la manière la plus de la
manière la plus claire et là je rappelle
aussi aux parlementaires que vous n'êtes
que le régime prudentiel de la caisse
des dépôts est l'une des principales
attributions de la commission de
surveillance de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations la structuration de la bp
le schéma présenté dans le projet de loi
nous initial nous va il nous parle est
le plus à même atteindre le plus à même
d'atteindre l'objectif d'efficacité
recherché par la création d' abbey pays
en évitant des conflits d'intérêts entre
financement et investissement comme je
le veux indiquer le précédemment et la
bpi aussi aura bien évidemment pour
vocation d'investir comme nous le
faisons déjà à travers un certain nombre
d'outils comme le fait aussi oseo par le
biais de cofinancement de cons
investissements qui devront être
privilégiés les modalités d'intervention
de la bpi dans les activités les
missions d'intérêt général devront être
iliad - intégrer leur financement est du
ressort du budget et
de l'état pour la plupart en la bpi peut
intervenir en complément
mais cela devra être bien évidemment
précisé et nous devrons avoir bien
évidemment dans le cas de cette baby un
rendement minimal des capitaux engagés
c'est ce que je voulais dire on a ce que
j'ai dit en introduction pour protéger
les intérêts patrimoniaux de l'état
alors il y a un problème pour être très
clair avec vous qui doit encore être
tranchée qui est celui de jeu les dix la
structure telle qu'elle est proposée
dans le projet de loi convient à la
caisse des dépôts
deuxièmement nous voyons fleurir en ce
qui concerne la holding de la bpi un
certain nombre de modifications
comme vous le savez le directeur général
de la caisse des dépôts est pressenti
pour présider la bpi dont je ne voudrais
pas après avoir été soumis à la question
sur beaucoup de conflits d'intérêts me
trouvait encore au centre de conflits
d'intérêts moi je vous dirais la chose
suivante et je vais partager la parole
avec antoine gosset grainville nous
comprenons très bien que la holding de
la bpi soit considéré comme un
établissement de crédit
ça nous paraît tout à fait bonnes choses
que quel soit considéré comme un
établissement de crédit
nous comprenons très bien que l'on
souhaite aller vite dans la mise en
place de la bpi après je dire c'est à
l'état et à la représentation nationale
de dire quelle doit être la récap et les
conséquences et la forme de
ce que doit constituer la holding comme
établissement de crédit c'est c'est un
problème politique que le savoir si au
capital de l'aldi vous avez ou non la
présence de banque privée au capital
d'une banque publique d'investissement
c'est ni au président putatif de la bpi
de décider et c'est encore moins au
directeur général de la caisse des
dépôts de le dire c'est pas un problème
technique c'est un problème politique
parce que la présence de bancs au
capital de la holding de la bpi signifie
qu'il y aura bien évidemment un des
représentants des banques qui seront à
ce capital qui seront qui sera
vraisemblablement qui aura une
responsabilité
peut-être pas au conseil
d'administration mais tout au moins
comme censeur de la banque publique
d'investissement une fois que j'ai dit
cela
moi je laisse le parlement en délibéré
nous ce qui est important jeudi pour la
caisse des dépôts c'est quel que soit le
choix de l'état quel que soit le choix
du parlement doit y avoir un équilibre
actionnarial atx lui entre l'état tu
peut céder une partie de ses
participations mois pour faciliter les
choses à des banques c'est ou à d'autres
établissements publics
c'est pas le problème du directeur
général de la caisse des dépôts mais
pour le reste doit y avoir un équilibre
actionnarial très claire entre l'état et
la caisse des dépôts
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire mais je
vais laisser parce qu'il est la parole
plus libre que moi sur ce point
monsieur vient c'est grave il si vous
permettez monsieur le président bien
préciser la position avec le sait et
pose un problème important
merci beaucoup je vais être très bref et
prolongez simplement sur ce point précis
ce que le directeur général vient de
vient d'indiquer donc effectivement les
discussions se poursuivent entre l'état
les représentants d'états ceux de la
caisse des dépôts et le préfigurateur
sur le bon statut de la structure de
tête de la bpi la question étant
concrètement est-ce que de savoir si la
bpi doit être une compagnie financière
comme cela était envisagé jusqu'à
présent on devrait plutôt être un
établissement de crédit de plein
exercice et si on devait être dans ce
deuxième cas de figure si cet
établissement de crédit pourrait être
oséo ou devrait être un nouvel
établissement de crédit qui aurait deux
filiales oseo d'une part et la branche
investissement d'autre part comme cela
est évoqué et été été initialement
envisagé dans nos travaux techniquement
tout est possible je mentionnerai
seulement le fait que la formule de
l'établissement de crédit semble avoir
la sympathie de l'autorité de contrôle
prudentiel qui si elle n'écarte aucun
schéma
elle dit qu'elle peut vivre avec tous
les schémas mais elle trouve que
l'établissement de crédit à présent des
avantages en terme de gouvernance et de
de supervision bancaire de notre de
notre côté nous sommes animés par
l'objectif principal de retenir la
structure qui sera la plus efficace et
donc nous conduisons ces discussions la
manière la plus pragmatique qui puisse
être
et donc si ce doit être un établissement
de crédit c'est quelque chose que nous
pouvons tout à fait envisager pouvons en
voir également les avantages
néanmoins et c'est le point que le
directeur général vient d'évoquer sur
lequel je me permets de
de revenir un instant parce qu'il est
important il nous paraît très important
de s'assurer qu'en réglant un problème
technique
on ne remettent pas en cause l'équilibré
actionnarial est ta caisse des dépôts
qui est la clé de voûte du projet pour
toute une série de raisons sur
lesquelles nous reviendrons évidemment
si vous le souhaitez et cette exigence
nous conduit à rechercher des solutions
qui ne remettent pas en cause la
détention par la caisse des dépôts de
50% de la bpi
il y a plusieurs formules qui permettent
cela donc c'est un peu dans cet esprit
là que nous travaillons mais il nous
semble
au delà des considérations politiques
qui prime
comme l'a rappelé le directeur général
pour beaucoup de raisons il nous semble
très important que le schéma quel qu'il
soit préserve bien le principe d'une
détention de la bpi par la caisse des
dépôts à 50%
merci simplement mes chers collègues
pour le peut-être pour vous éclairer ce
qui vient d'être évoquée à la fois par
directeur général directeur général
adjoint
j'ai demandé qu'on fasse un petit
montage de ce qui est imaginée à l'heure
actuelle pour qu'on comprenne la holding
et les deux filiales et les pourcentages
de participation de la caisse
je crois que c'est important par rapport
ce que vous venez dire messieurs pour
que tout le monde soit sur la même même
niveau d'information est sans doute le
problème que vous évoquez c'est vrai
qu'il est pas simplement technique elle
est aussi politique et en particulier la
participation de 10% si j'ai bien
compris dans le schéma initial de banque
privée dans la partie aux héros voilà
c'est quelque chose qui va falloir
trancher donc que les messieurs les deux
rapporteurs vous avez en priorité la
parole est donc un peu importe lequel va
dire oui merci le seul prénom
je veux qu'on moment où il s'agit de
préciser les missions de la bpi la
proche de l'accord pardon la proche de
la commission des landes durable doit
s'effectuer sous l'angle de la
transition écologique comme l'a évoqué
effectivement monsieur le président
valls vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
président à l'occasion effectivement du
rôle de zéro notamment dans la
préparation de la transition énergétique
quelques questions si vous le permettez
avez vous une idée de la stratégie
globale que poursuivra la bpi notamment
pour favoriser cette transition
énergétique et coordonnée les nombreuses
initiatives qui apparaissent en
différents points du territoire
comment concevez-vous le rôle des
comités régionaux d'orientation
notamment leur articulation avec le
comité national
comment pensez vous assurer l'objectif
de suivi des entreprises
à chacune des phases au redéveloppement
merci
monsieur burqa et messieurs ce directeur
général faut savoir que l'ensemble des
élus des entreprises attendent avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de commandes
d'impatience mais aussi il ya une attend
surtout des entreprises d'une économique
est en difficulté ils attendent beaucoup
de cette banque publique
d'investissement et en même temps ils
savent ses élus ses entreprises qu'il
existe deux dans de nombreux domaines
de nombreux outils de financement et la
question qui se pose quel et quelle sera
la valeur ajoutée de la bpi par rapport
à l'existant
là c'est la première question parce que
comment en pleine crise lorsqu'il y a eu
la grande crise et que nous étions en
région il y avait des cellules en
préfecture qui serait une cei qu'oseo et
on regardait avec beaucoup de proximité
beaucoup de réactivité de simplicité
quelle aide apporter aux entreprises et
les questions sont très claires quels
sont les besoins pas ou mal satisfait
sur laquelle la bpi va apprendre et
apporter des réponses
le financement de la trésorerie par
exemple le crédit et la garantie à
l'exportation l'articulation entre
l'offre de financement et
l'accompagnement des entreprises et en
particulier sur la question des fonds
propres
malade et des questions qui sont très
forts deuxième question plus générale
mais vous l'avez déjà abordé tout à
l'heure quelle sera la doctrine
d'investissement de la bpi 1 re
définition ou évolution de cette
doctrine par rapport à oséo est toujours
par rapport aux outils existants
quels sont les critères d'investissement
en termes de risque
et de rentabilité ce qui seront les
mêmes voilà la question de la
compétitivité est au coeur du débat
politique français
aujourd'hui concernant la structuration
des filières considèrent concernant
l'aide aux entreprises
est-ce que sur cette question de la
compétitivité estimant notamment ce
crédit concernant qui vient d'être mis
en place
qu'elle pourrait prendre quelle serait
la place de l'abbé pays dans ce domaine
voilà toute une série de questions
auxquelles nous sommes vraiment très
attaché et nous pensons que nous devons
sortir de ce débat parlementaire avec un
produit tout à fait nouveau une
institution nouvelles qui facilitent le
développement économique en région et
qui facilite le développement économique
au niveau national
si j'ai à l'heure actuelle presque une
dizaine de demandes de prise de parole
en sachant que 11h15 noyant avoir fini
donc au plus tard est-ce que vous
souhaitez répondre aux deux rapporteurs
d'abord mais les remettait pour répondre
à monsieur le porte heureux mais très
tôt tout d'abord ce que je fais est
indiqué sur la transition énergétique
c'est que la bpi va
rationaliser nos dispositifs
d'intervention en ce domaine nous
intervenons aujourd'hui par
le biais du fsi vous avez plus d'un
milliard d'euros qui est consacrée à ces
interventions vous comme je les dis vous
avez les prêts oséo les prêts verts et
économies d'énergie
vous avez également les prêts éco
technologies qui ont été lancées par cdc
entreprises et c'est une des priorités
fixées par la bpi ce la caisse des
dépôts est très présente sur ce sujet de
la transition énergétique notamment à
l'égard de cdc climat et comme vous le
savez également dans le cadre des fonds
d'investissements d'avenir dans les pme
et donc vous avez des interventions à la
fois un capital et en prêts sur un
ensemble des pme pour développer tout ce
qui est énergie renouvelable tout ce qui
est transition écologique tout ce qui
est réhabilitation énergétique d'un
certain nombre de logements enfin tous
amis le nous le faisons aujourd'hui ce
que je peux dire c'est que l'ensemble de
ses activités y compris celle de cdc
climat et des fonds de programme
d'investissements d'avenir seront et qui
sont gérés par ces entreprises seront
automatiquement transférés à la bp et
qu'il y aura une articulation de plus en
plus étroite avec ce qui se fait en ce
domaine et notamment au niveau des
directions régionales de la caisse des
dépôts donc tout sera ce sera coordonnée
et apporter à la banque publique
d'investissement deuxième aspect sur les
comités régionaux d'orientation et
comités nationaux votre question et
pertinents elle vaut également pour les
comités d'engagement et d'investissement
je le dis pour d'autres questions sire
que nous devrons déterminer selon moi là
je je je reprends à titre personnel
parce qu'il n'y a pas encore eu de
décision prise au niveau des conseils
d'administration des organes de
gouvernance de l'avant mais vous devrez
avoir des seuils d'intervention au
niveau
e régional des seuils d'intervention
niveau national qui seront décidées par
chacune des filiales qui peuvent être
différentes d'ailleurs lorsque vous
investissez en capital lorsque vous avez
si c'est en fonds propres et doit y
avoir une articulation très très forte
de deux rapports entre ce qui existera
au niveau régional sorte de guichet
unique dans les comités d'engagement et
comité d'investissement et les
orientations stratégiques qui seront
retenues et donc doit y avoir c'est un
système de reporting en mauvais français
et d'instruction des dossiers très
étroitement liée entre le niveau
national et le niveau régional de façon
c'est votre troisième question assurer
un suivi simplifié pour les entreprises
l'accession de monsieur bourquin
également suivi ci soient simplifiées
coordonnées et qu'elle n'est plus à
à s'adresser comme c'est le cas
actuellement
soit des directions territoriales de la
caisse soit des organismes différents de
la caisse des dépôts soit à oséo mais
que en fonction du financement de
l'accompagnement des entreprises ou de
l'intervention en fonds propres et bien
à chaque fois un des interlocuteurs qui
soit bien identifié des comités qui
suivent l'ensemble des dossiers et le
niveau régional doit également capté des
dossiers intéressants
le niveau y ait un rôle de capteur de
dossiers capteurs d'initiatives pour
répondre aux deux rapporteurs qui doit
se faire en région et qui doit se faire
de manière professionnelle moi j'ai
visité un certain nombre de régions la
semaine dernière ce qui m'a frappé c'est
que on le faisait sans le savoir on le
faisait de manière un peu éclaté et que
moi le principal avantage que je vois
dans tout ça c'est de formaliser et de
2,2 de coordonnées et de simplifier et
de donner un visage et d'incarner au
niveau régional une nous sommes des
initiatives déjà éclaté la danse est une
des valeurs ajoutées pour répondre à
monsieur bourquin de la bpi par rapport
à l'existant et puis l'autre valeur
ajoutée c'est effectivement de prendre
en compte des besoins qui sont mal
satisfait vous avez tout ce qui existe
en trésorerie vous avez effectivement
l'accompagnement export et vous avez
développement de ce qui est en fonds
propres sur les plus petites entreprises
et sur les entreprises de taille
intermédiaire sur la doctrine
d'investissement de l'abbé pij de doit
rappeler c'est tout ce qui est centrée
sur pme et bpi ce qui veut dire que l'on
n'exclut pas d'avoir des filières qu'on
aura des filières aussi a déjà compté
compétitivité moi je pense à
l'automobile je pense à l'aéronautique
je pense à d'autres types de filiales
une filière aussi écologique énergies
renouvelables tout ce que vous ai dit
mais on peut pas non plus multiplié les
filières à l'infini on va intervenir je
sais qu'un certain nombre d'entre vous
ils sont très sensibles avaient payé
interviendra dans les investissements
dans le numérique
mais avant que la doctrine
d'investissement de la bpi soit précisée
dans le du mien il faudrait que la
doctrine de l'état sur l'intervention en
humains soient précises
la bpi sera un outil au service aussi de
la doctrine d'intervention de l'état en
matière de numérique et de très haut
débit et de couvertures tout au début du
territoire mais là il faut que nous
ayons des orientations qui nous soit
donnée par étape pour que la bpi puis
est intervenu en risque et en
responsabilité et en rentabilité bien là
je vous dis au regard de ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui ne garderont les
mêmes niveaux de risques et nous
n'exagérons pas en termes de rentabilité
nous cherchons à voir des rentabilités
raisonnable on n'est pas là la bpi n'est
pas là pour faire ça ce fait tant mieux
enfin avoir des taux de rendements les
plus élevés c'est pas le rôle de la bpi
qui intervient en complément de ce que
font les banques et les marchés et on
reviendra également lorsqu'il y aura des
carences de marché sur un certain nombre
de domaines
voilà merci je le directeur je sais bien
ce schéma lac que vous avez oui d'accord
qui a été distribué pour qu'on comprenne
initial ok bon monsieur vaugrenard tous
les merci monsieur le président il est
donc beaucoup attendu de la part de la
bpi mais également de la puissance
publique derrière la banque publique
d'investissement pour soutenir
l'activité économique
les régions en particulier attendre
comportement offensif notamment pour
soutenir les pme et faire qu'il ya un
peu plus de d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaire sur le territoire mais
également parfois également la recherche
et d'innovation bien entendu mais aussi
parfois parce que ça arrive notamment
dans la période économique que nous
traversons d'avoir une intervention
défensif
c'est ce que nous avons fait au niveau
de notre région par exemple du fait de
la situation économique difficile un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui
pouvaient être considérées comme étant
des cannes à watten et passagers se sont
trouvés avec un carnet commandes
momentanément vides alors c'était
entreprise extrêmement concurrentiel
extrêmement content
performante par ailleurs et donc le but
c'était de leur fait faire passer ce
moment difficile
moyennant un prêt le début de
remboursement commence en 24 mois ou 36
mois après l'obtention de ce prêt donc
là je veux parler du rôle de la bpi de
manière défensive mais efficace et donc
ça ne doit pas être considérée ou si
c'est le terme est impropre comme des
canards boiteux le rôle des régions vous
savez inquiète non pas les régions mais
elle souhaiterait s'impliquer être
impliqué très fortement dans le
fonctionnement de la bpi dans
l'obtention des prêts et dans la
connaissance également que doivent avoir
les entreprises des possibilités qui
leur sont offertes
très souvent c'est une absence
d'information une communication qui fait
qu'un certain nombre d'entreprises ne
savent pas de quoi elle pourrait
éventuellement disposer ou bénéficier en
termes de prêts il me semble que les
guichet unique et les plateformes que
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure devrait
être sous la responsabilité des
assemblées régionales ou co piloté avec
la banque publique d'investissement mais
non pas comme vous l'évoquez tout à
l'heure la banque publique
d'investissement en associant les
régions je dis cela parce que les
régions ont fait la démonstration je
vais être très bref dalian ont fait la
démonstration depuis quelques années de
leur efficacité dans leur soutien à
l'activité économique notamment des
petites et moyennes entreprises
donc là où ça fonctionne bien là où ça
marche bien je pense qu'il est plus
utile de travailler en bonne
concertation et de manière extrêmement
décentralisée j'aimerais que vous soyez
plus précis par rapport à cela
sur le fait que les plateformes serait
plutôt sur la responsabilité des régions
en associant reviennent bien entendu la
banque publique d'investissement et non
pas l'inversé
comme nous l'avions évoqué tout à
l'heure merci je crois que c'est une des
questions un peu difficile qui est posée
et nous devions auditionné monsieur
rousset cet après midi mais il
nulle et sur rendez vous je suis
persuadé que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler de cette relation entre les
régions
et justement cette bpi même
décentralisée enfin peu importe les
plateformes
je crois que c'est un des enjeux
monsieur noël un pardon je me suis
trompé tromper de bras
priorité aux actions
il faut toujours un opérateur majeur
alors moi j'aimerais savoir qui va
diriger c'est l'état ou sept
la caisse des dépôts et moi je
souhaiterais que ce soit la caisse des
dépôts l'état doit contrôler doit
administrer doit accompagner ne doit pas
se substituer aux opérateurs c'est une
philosophie qui est la mienne je dis
simplement que aujourd'hui il faut pas
qu'on se rentre renvoient la balle en 10
ans baisse et à l'état ou c est moi je
souhaiterais qui est à majorité à 51
pour ça on peut trouver des solutions
intelligentes
le deuxième point ce qui m'inquiète vous
l'avez souligné c'est le fait qu' il y
ait des banques privées en aval parce
qu'évidemment il vont être au courant
des dossiers et vous imaginer ce qui va
se passer c'est à dire que
l'intervention des banques privées au
contact des entreprises va faire en
sorte qu'ils seront toujours les
premiers sur les opérations et donc là
je crois qu'il faut légitimer un
processus qui permette de bien contrôler
les opérations qui vont se passer je l'
ai vécu pendant 30 ans un institut
régional développement industriel dont
vous êtes actionnaire avec 22% et le
conseil régional est 20% et des restants
nous évoquons des dossiers en corse
administration va immédiatement les
opérateurs privés prennent ces dossiers
et il anticipe alors c'est pas forcément
mauvais pour les industriels puisque
c'est la compétition est un facteur de
progrès pour autant attention dans la
gestion des opérations
voilà troisièmement on nous avait
annoncé cette des pays comme intervenant
assez rapidement quel est le délai que
vous nous donnez pour l'intervention
parce que malheureusement les
entreprises vont pas attendre longtemps
aujourd'hui entre les besoins des
entreprises et nos besoins des
collectivités
le problème est lourd et nous avons des
besoins de financement pour les
collectivités et entre 15 et 20
milliards par le fait que dexia
n'intervient plus et quant aux
entreprises et notamment pour les fonds
de roulement vous avez oublié du reste
l'agroalimentaire je vous rappelle que
l'agroalimentaire ses 12 milliard de
positif dans la balance commerciale vous
avez cité un certain nombre de secteurs
qui certes ont des besoins mais
n'oubliez pas l'agroalimentaire qui
irrigue tout nos territoires et
particulièrement le rural donc je
souhaiterais que je sais qu'on oublie
souvent ça me ferait plaisir que vous
devrez été grillés voilà merci dit
monsieur guillaume et monsieur messieurs
les présidents que le directeur général
d'abord je crois que on peut dire que
actuellement les collectivités locales
n'ont qu'à se louer des relations
qu'elles entretiennent avec la caisse
des dépôts et dans beaucoup d'endroits
en tout cas ces banques a avec oséo pour
l'aide aux entreprises
nous avons signé des conventions justine
une dernière là mon département de la
drôme
ça se passe remarquablement bien et
c'est très important de pour aborder ces
sujets de développement économique au
plus près du terrain
sachant que l'organisme est un organisme
national
si je crois ce qui fait la force
deuxième chose par rapport à ce qui
était évoqué quand françois hollande
mais là bas plus les investissements
dans ces 60 engagement et dans un des
tous d'une des touches du clavier de sa
politique de développement économique et
industriel et de redressement productif
c'est bien parce qu'il y avait un manque
et que le aujourd'hui ce que nous
pouvons constater nous dans nos régions
dans nos départements
c'est que un entrepreneur un chef
d'entreprise quelle que soit la taille
s'il a besoin de rien il va voir une
banque qui sera bien accueilli mais s'il
a besoin d' aide et s'il est en
difficulté c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et donc qu'il était important que la
puissance publique que le politique vous
avez bien fait de dire ces politiques ce
dossier prenne ses responsabilités je
sais pas ce qui sortira à l'arrivée ce
que le parlement décidera sur
proposition du chef de l'état et du
gouvernement mais c'est bien à partir
d'une orientation politique que nous
mettrons cela en place parce que
aujourd'hui ce que nous constatons
savait dès le départ notre collègue mais
ça date pas d'hier c'est que les
collectivités ne peuvent pas financer ou
ne peuvent plus financer et que dans
cette période de crise terrible
les entreprises ont du mal à avoir accès
au crédit ou ont du mal à développer
leur
leur leur entreprise et même un peu de
difficulté et nubuck renard me disait on
peut penser à ce mot affreux de canards
boiteux mais qu'est ce que c'est un
canard boiteux
ces syriens que la préfiguration d'un
canard qui marchera bien quand sa patte
sera réparé nous battre a plu non mais
c'est aussi cela est la troisième chose
que je voulais évoquer c'est que le
redressement économique de notre pays
il passera évidemment par des grandes
entreprises par des entreprises symbole
ce qui peut se passer aujourd'hui ou
demain ou dans les jours qui viennent à
florange est quelque chose d'essentiel
quant à la parole publique parce que
cette parole publique a été bafoué on
devait sauver les au four de gandrange
ne sont pas sauvés et florange est en
train peut-être de crever ça c'est un
manquement à la parole publique et quand
nos concitoyens ne croient plus en la
politique c'est aussi à cause de cela
mais demain nous devons répondre à des
questions très précises et j'essaie de
faire plus court possible monsieur le
président vous démarrez vos auditions
une demi-heure avant une vie de
questions très précises nous il ya une
demande forte des élus et des
entreprises que la bpi investissent moi
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent
qu'elle doit investir il faut orienter
les fonds vers la réindustrialisation et
l'innovation plutôt que vers la finance
c'est quelque chose qui me semble assez
important donc la question qui a été qui
a été posée c'est quand est ce que les
choses avanceront se mettront en place
ça ça fera partie de la loi mais moi la
question qui m'aiment pas parce qu'elle
est à mon avis essentiel c'est quelle
articulation régionales
comment et si c'est la question
essentielle que nous allons avoir à
évoquer
nous avons aujourd'hui le débat avec les
régions et c'est pas un débat politique
lorsque l'on est dans la majorité
gouvernementale puisque nous sommes pas
pour nous emporter de la même orientés
organisation politique mais il n'empêche
que pour moi la mise en place de l'abbé
pays ça ne peut pas être me semble-t-il
les pleins pouvoirs aux régions dans le
traitement de leur dossier et il faut
trouver l'articulation entre la force de
la puissance publique
le savoir-faire des régions mais
également aller au plus près des petites
entreprises qui elles créent de l'emploi
tous les jours merci monsieur le vice
président monsieur testons merci
monsieur le président ce directeur
général l'information que vous nous avez
donné ce matin en cours de votre exposé
ainsi que le tableau qui nous a été
remis par la suite font apparaître que
la banque publique d'investissement
investissements constituera une holding
contrôlant à 100% des pays
investissements qui devraient intégrer
le fonds stratégique d'investissement
alors le fonds stratégique
d'investissement détient nombreuses
participations dans des groupes français
sur le directeur général vous auriez
laissé entendre que la bpi pouvait
sortir d'un certain nombre de groupes et
en particulier selon vos propres termes
ceux qui n'en ont pas besoin
alors je ne sais pas si cette
information est confirmée cette
orientation confirmée en tout cas il est
bien que vous ayez une réflexion sur la
question il est bien que les futurs
responsables la bpi est une réflexion
sur la question il me paraît essentiel
que le gouvernement pose qui le concerne
le parlement pour ce qui le concerne
puisse effectivement s'exprimer sur la
question de savoir quels sont les
groupes qui ne nécessite plus de
bénéficier de capitaux publics
et quels sont ceux qui méritent de
continuer à en bénéficier
c'est un débat à mon avis fondamental
sur lequel je souhaiterais connaître
votre avis
imagine que vous avez en tête hrt normes
d'entreprises publiques en particulier
monsieur d'aunis ensuite monsieur ma
grasse c'est le président monsieur le
débat général sur collègues partagent eu
beaucoup de ce qui a été dit
précédemment particulièrement par didier
guillaume et me centrer sur deux
questions la première problématique de
l'articulation avec j'allais dire le
terrain symbolisée par la région dans le
débat mais je crois que c'est au delà de
la région demande parce qu'on a des
organisations territoriales les
départements les métropoles les agglos
bien et quand on se rappelle que sur les
68 et quelques milliards
d'investissements publics portés par les
collectivités
il ya quand même 39,3 1 c'est tout ce
qui est collectivités c'est 70% chapelle
de l'investissement public
ça représente 60 de plus quasiment 69
médias et y en a trente neuf qui se
relèvent du secteur communal donc ma
proposition serait que nous puissions
parce qu'on ne peut pas avoir une
représentation de toutes les agglos de
tous les bars te ment dans les comités
d'orientation de toutes les régions
qu'on essaye d'avoir un levier qui soit
par exemple là un représentant de la
fédération d
établissements publics locaux société
d'économistes spl qui permet comme ça
d'avoir un maillage de ceux qui seront
le levier de l'investissement sur le
terrain c'est une proposition d'ailleurs
une part est très utile que cette
fédération au niveau national la
fédération nationale des ep hell puis 7
au conseil d'orientation
je voulais savoir votre sentiment
connaissant l'importance de l'économie
mixte heures ce qui dans les efforts que
nous devons faire la deuxième question
la bpi est aussi concerné par l'économie
sociale et solidaire dont elle avait
tout à leur parler en ce qui concerne la
politique gouvernementale en ce domaine
elle est affirmée de la part du
gouvernement qui a dit que seraient
mobilisés devrait recevoir délégation de
fond ce soit france active ou l'a dit je
voulais savoir quelle est l articulation
avec la loi en préparation telle que
vous l'envisagez quelles seraient les
formules de type certificat de
mutualistes ou titre associative
participatif que cela pourrait revêtir
pour donner toute sa place à le ssp si
monsieur le directeur général je vous
propose de répondre à cette série de
questions vois ce que je pense que
l'essentiel dans tous les cas de l'enjeu
politique qui ont été posées et après on
reprendra la suite des questions merci
beaucoup monsieur le président je vais
le faire avec la 2 d'antoine gosset
grainville notamment sur les
50 50 je vais préciser deux choses
d'abord à l'égard de 2,2 d'abord de
monsieur mogren de jeu vaugrenard
d'autres qui ont évoqué les moments
difficiles et les canards boiteux
il se trouve que moi j'ai pas l'habitude
de pratiquer trop la langue de bois
les canards boiteux j'ai employé cette
expression
après avoir été à l'assemblée des
régions de france ou quatre ou cinq
présidents des régions ont dit que la
bpi ne soutiendrait pas les canards
boiteux
donc je n'ai fait que reprendre quatre
ou cinq déclarations de responsables
politiques présidents de région 1 donc
maintenant une fois moi c'est dit là on
cherche on trouve
le premier point et c'est pas moi qui
les ai inventées parce que d'une part je
sais pas bien ce que c'était moins
parlants voilà bon enfin c'est pas moi
en tout cas qu'il est qu'il est dit mais
enfin il se trouve que vous n'avez pas
d'audition cet imprimé président de
l'assemblée des régions de france donc
c'est dommage voilà mais je lui poserai
la poserai la question c'est bien mais
ça viendra alors mais en revanche plus
sérieusement quand il ya des moments
difficiles monsieur vaugrenard on sait
faire et la caisse des dépôts
c'est faire s'il faut passer par des
prêts que ce soit oseo ou la caisse des
dépôts on saura faire pour faire face à
des solutions défensives comme vous ne
l'avez dit sur le le le le fait que
nous puissions faire en sorte que
trouver des solutions temporaires on le
fait déjà
on le fait déjà dans votre région dans
votre région
il ya de la construction navale sur la
construction navale qui est-ce qui
intervient dans les moments difficiles
si ce n'est la caisse des dépôts coco
qu'est ce qui est à qui on a demandé
d'intervenir à chaque fois assister à la
caisse des dépôts s'est pas l'état qui
est intervenu premier point deuxièmement
quand sur le 1% logement
il ya des difficultés et qu'il y a des
solutions défensives a trouvé sur le
logement qui à qui on demande
d'intervenir c'est pas le budget de
l'état c'est la caisse des dépôts
ces défauts ont dépeint c'est nous qui
allons soutenir pendant trois ans une
politique immobilière du logement donc
on sait faire et on saura faire dans le
cadre de la bpi et je ne veux pas qu'on
croit que la caisse des dépôts ne sait
pas prendre de solutions défensives et
sur le plan industriel et sur le plan du
logement et sur le plan de l'activité
sociale et je rejoins ce qu'a dit
monsieur guillaume sur la parole
publique veut dire que sur florange
si un projet et si un projet intéressant
et si lé projet qui qui qui qui
permettent effectivement de tenir la
parole publique et bien la banque
publique d'investissement ou auparavant
le fonds stratégique d'investissement
sera faire s'il ya des projets vous me
donnez les projets sur flanc et on le
fera
bon donc je voudrais que sur ces choses
là ce soit clair et qu'on sache qu'on
est capable également d'avoir des
activités défensives qu'on est capable
d'avoir une vision qui est axé sur la
réindustrialisation que pour ma part je
les dis extrêmement clairement je crois
que la banque publique d'investissement
doit être une banque qui doit être au
service de la réindustrialisation des
territoires que c'est une banque qui
doit être au service de la défense de
l'activité industrielle et territoires
c'est une banque aussi qui doit être au
service de le ddd j'allais dire des six
vous avez des activités de services qui
doivent également être soutenu et c'est
pas une banque qui a vocation à soutenir
les activités financières mais bien les
activités productives donc je le dit
extrêmement clairement de ce point de
vue là et à rechercher le rendement pour
le rendement votre clair avez vous alors
la seconde grande question qui a été
posée à la fois par monsieur vaugrenard
par monsieur guillaume que monsieur
testons également à reprise c'est
l'articulation avec les régions moi je
veux être clair avec vous cette question
là elle est politique elle est politique
nous ferons nous en tant que responsable
technique de la caisse des dépôts
comme vous l'avez dit monsieur guillaume
nous chercherons à faire en sorte de
faire aussi bien en simplifiant les
procédures que ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui avec les présidents de
conseils régionaux de département et
d'agglomération mais si on se parle
franchement là aussi et monsieur
question là bien de donner le pardon a
bien souligné oui je m'excuse monsieur
donné par non non non non non mais je
vais lui répondre également à monsieur
question
c'est ce qui ce qui est dit c'est que
j'ai un son de cloche des présidents
d'agglomérations des présidents des
grandes villes et des présidents des
régions
c'est pas à moi de le résoudre donc moi
il me faut une réponse là dessus et la
réponse elle doit venir du parlement et
du gouvernement je ferai ce je
m'inscrirai dans le cadre qui sera dit
et au niveau des comités d'engagement et
au niveau des comités d'orientation
j'ai mon opinion là dessus je voulais
donner on peut ne pas la partager
et après je ferai en fonction de ce que
seront les choix politiques arbitrée par
le président de la république et le
premier ministre
non je suis extrêmement clair sur le
sujet et je suis favorable je le dis à
monsieur de nice à ce qu'il y ait
effectivement les
je paie l île et représentants d opel et
des sociétés des communistes au conseil
d'orientation de la bp moi ça me paraît
intelligent personnellement alors en ce
qui concerne les autres questions sur
les délais d'intervention le premier
conseil d'administration devrait avoir
lieu en janvier plutôt dans la deuxième
quinzaine de 2 2 janvier de la bpi après
l'approbation de la loi les opérations
d'apport
je vais revenir là c'est la crise c'est
bien la question de monsieur testons
suppose l'y aider des leds les
autorisations de bruxelles
la consultation des institutions
représentatives du personnel à oseo et à
la caisse des dépôts et bien évidemment
des commissaires aux apports ce qui
nécessite quand même là plusieurs mois
et ce qui va nous amener au cours du
second trimestre 2013 sur ces opérations
techniques mais ce que je veux je veux
vous rassurer mes amis et messieurs les
sénateurs sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
solution de rupture
c'est dire que et la caisse des dépôts
et le fonds stratégique d'investissement
et oseo vont continuer à travailler
pendant ses temps on va faire le pontage
et on va faire là là j'allais dire
organisa organise organiser la
continuité des actions entre la mise en
place de la bpi et ceux qui existent
sera pas de solution de rupture on va
continuer à travailler
tel que l'on fait actuellement et c'est
tout le travail que rempli avec une
grande efficacité ni connaître dufour
que actuellement voilà ce que je
souhaitais vous indiquez sur pour
répondre à monsieur testons avant que de
laisser la parole à antoine gosset
grainville sur 50 50 et le le le
la doctrine j'ai pas paraître de sortie
de groupe ce qui se passe
monsieur testons sait qu'on va être
obligé de faire des apports pour
respecter les parités justement
actionnariale et il ya des sessions qui
vont se faire de la caisse des dépôts à
l'état donc c'est la question des
apports que l'on devra résoudre
on est on intervient aujourd'hui dans le
cadre du fonds stratégique
d'investissement vont être obligés de
céder un certain nombre de
participations pour respecter les
apports ça c'est le premier point
le second point ce qui peut se passer
c'est quelle que soit la nature des
entreprises mais plus privé que puis
c'est que il ya toujours une certaine
rotation d'actifs
nous avons des investissements à la
quasi dépendant des investissements
privés qui ne sont pas stratégiques je
ne citerai pas pour mais que ces
personnes il y en a d'autres qui peuvent
le devenir demain bien pour ça nous
avons nous sommes dans l'obligation
d'avoir une certaine politique de
rotation d'actifs j'allais dire
intelligent pour faire en sorte que les
capitaux mis à la disposition de cette
banque publique d'investissement soient
les plus élevées possibles à ce que je
voulais dire avant de passer la parole à
antoine qui est le gros species 55 ans
oui c'est pas des spécialisations les
plus excitants bon d'abord il n'ya pas
de doute que un schéma actionnariale à
50/50 ça n'est pas une formule idéale
c'est pal et les modes de fonctionnement
les plus les plus faciles cela dit
l'état et la caisse des dépôts ont
l'expérience déjà du co pilotage
d'entreprise est le meilleur exemple
c'est le fsi alors le fsi s'est 51/49
mais on est bien dans un copilotage et
depuis trois ans depuis que le fsi a été
créé il n'y a pas eu un cas de désaccord
entre l'état et la caisse des dépôts sur
des décisions d'investissement c'est un
le mode de fonctionnement a été d'une
fluidité totale
et comme vous le savez il ya eu plus de
60 investissements qui ont été faits le
fsi a été le premier fonds
d'investissement français d' extrêmement
- et sans jamais un cas de désaccord ou
de blocage alors au delà de ça au delà
de ça le schéma sur lequel nous avons
travaillé avec l'état pour la bpi est un
schéma qui permet de garantir d'assurer
sur la branche investissement
une prééminence de la caisse des dépôts
qui est un choix qui a paru extrêmement
souhaitable et nécessaire
d'abord parce que la caisse des dépôts
est traditionnellement tiers de
confiance vis-à-vis des entreprises
elle est perçue depuis longtemps comme
un investisseur responsable très engagé
un opérateur qu'elles connaissent bien
et qu'elle solliciterait souvent il
fallait donc préserver cette cette
situation et ensuite vis-à-vis de
bruxelles
parce qu'il était très important de
montrer que la doctrine d'investissement
du fsi et de cdc entreprises doctrine
d'investissement qsl d'un investisseur
avisé de long terme que cette option
d'investissement était totalement
préservée dans le nouveau cadre de la
bpi la commission européenne achète
pleinement cette doctrine
elles lui sont totalement conformes aux
règles communautaires en particulier sur
les aides d'état et donc il fallait
voilà rassurés sur le fait que la
création de la bpi ne reviendrait pas à
remettre en cause cette situation et au
travers de la prééminence donner à la
caisse des dépôts dans la gouvernance de
la filiale d'investissement prêt
imminent ce qui se traduira par le fait
qu'il y aura un administrateur de plus
représentant la caisse des dépôts que
les administrateurs représentant l'état
est bien au travers de cette prééminence
on gère de manière effective si je puis
dire une situation actionnariale à 50/50
et on évite tout risque de blocage il me
reste encore six demandes de parole je
vous demande d'être et concis monsieur
ma grâce monsieur mort est monsieur
bérit-debat monsieur de monsieur cornano
monsieur dubois
j'ai pas vu
donc
non mais c'est pas le problème ne peut
pas deviner qui les bleus alors monsieur
ma grasse oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur général
c'est bien entendu la réponse que vous
avez apporté aux du rapporteur et à
l'ensemble de mes collègues sur le la
déclinaison régionale de la delà du
projet global
toutefois lors de la discussion de la
mission d'outre-mer à l'assemblée
nationale le ministre au maire a annoncé
une déclinaison spécifique dans chacun
des départements d'outre-mer et leur
chacune des collectivités d'outre-mer ma
question sera donc très courte est
double
pourriez vous nous donner des précisions
sur la mise en oeuvre de cette
organisation en outre-mer et des crédits
spécifiquement destinée à l'outre-mer
sont ils prévus
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président je vais
d'abord souligner le caractère très
claire de la présentation que nous a
faite le directeur général et dire que
nous allons je crois tous apprécié cette
présentation sa franchise et cette
absence de langue de bois
toutes qualités qui ne sont pas les plus
répandues dans la haute fonction
publique
je n'avais pas prévu jeune je n'avais
pas je n'avais pas prévu de non non je
ne suis pas issu de la fonction publique
aux chers collègues et là je me suis
mort s est là c'est évidemment j'avais
pas a prévu de prononcer le mot ce matin
mais vous l'avez fait donc je vais dire
deux mots là-dessus vous avez prononcé
un mot qui m'est qui me tient à coeur
c'est la question du numérique bon j'ai
souligné avec beaucoup d'intérêt de
satisfaction vous aviez dit que il était
nécessaire que l'état prenne position et
que vous aviez dit que la caisse des
dépôts était prête à investir en la
matière et je crois que la caisse des
dépôts un rôle essentiel à jouer en la
matière et j'espère qu'au cours d'une
prochaine audition on pourra plus
largement abordé ce sujet sur le sujet
du jour
je crois que un des grands avantages de
la bpi s'était largement dit c'est
d'arriver à fusionner une multitude de
structures et d'offrir ainsi une plus
grande clarification du paysage et par
là même sans doute le dégage plus grande
efficacité
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
qui est la suivante pourquoi n'at-il pas
été prévu d'essayer d'inclure dans ce
regroupement
l'agencé des participations de l'état je
vois que ça fait sourire monsieur 50 50
mais c'est me semble-t-il une question
parce que j'ai pu j'ai pu observer qu'il
y avait parfois des difficultés à
articuler le rôle de l'agencé des
participations de l'état avec le fsi et
même la caisse des dépôts
je pense que ça va ça pourrait être gage
d'une gestion plus dynamique des
participations de l'état et permettre
peut-être que celles ci soient elles
aussi plus orienté vers des
participations stratégiques
si monsieur claude bérit-debat oui ma
question ce sera très courte d'autant
que là elle a été déjà posé en partie
répondu c'est sur l'articulation entre
la région et le terrain en tant que
président d'une comptine agglomération
je rebondis sur les propos qui ont été
tenus par marc daunis et même si dans la
répartition des cohérences dans l'
architecture des collectivités locales
la région bien entendu et éminente en
matière de développement économique de
stratégie la question qui se pose quand
même ce sont les les les communes et les
aujourd'hui les counties l'agglomération
les comtés de communes qui joue un rôle
prédominant en matière d'investissements
aménagement des zones aménagements
d'hôtel d'entreprises aménagement de
deux pépinières dans c'est elle qui sont
le plus près le plus proche des
investisseurs dans ma question même si
vous avez dit que vous aviez des
demandes tout à fait contradictoires ou
différentes entre entre les régions les
départements et les représentants des
communautés d'agglomération d'une façon
générale
ma préoccupation c'est de voir comment
être le plus proche du terrain et
répondre je dirais de façon pertinente
et rapide à la demande des entreprises
de façon très forte proximité et
messieurs d'honneur oui vous avez déjà
répondu monsieur le directeur général un
certain nombre de mes préoccupations
mais je voudrais quand même faire
quelques observations une banque
publique dans ce pays il faut quand même
se méfier ça va modifier le paysage
bancaire traditionnel et gay prugo les
plus grandes krach bancaire des 30
dernières années ce sont étaient des
banques publiques il faut quand même
veut dire alors vous avez émis quelques
observe la fac est que principe sur les
conditions de gestion
moi je voudrais rappeler que
vous serez une banque mais soumis aux
mêmes règles de gestion mêmes règles
prudentielles que tout le monde et qu'il
faudra les respecter en ayant posé ça
c'est une construction originale qu'est
ce que vous allez pouvoir faire vous
avez amant semble ne pouvoir faire que
d'avoir un rôle d'orientation voir
d'aiguillon parce que par rapport au
financement des entreprises vous n'avez
pas de moyens le financement total des
entreprises dans ce pays c'est
sensiblement 1600 milliards
au mieux vous étiez fonds propres qu'on
annonce vous serez 45 50 milliards
d'interventions c'est à dire pas grand
chose donc vous ne pouvez oui vous ne
pouvez avoir carole d'orientation par
filière et d'aiguillon autrement on
n'attend pas après vous et c'est pas
utile - à l'heure donc bien choisir les
filières mais il faut être très clair
vous pouvez raccourcir bien choisir vos
filières et puis après comment avez vous
faire dans les régions pour avoir des
déconnexions avec les banques
coopératives qui dans ce pays représente
plus de 60 % du pnb et qui sont des
républiques autonomes régional et grands
réseaux sont faits de banques régionales
autonomes
c'est pas des choux nationale qui
commande il faut cent ans après et un
autre point que je voulais voir à quel
taux avez-vous pouvoir sortir et
apolitique de la caisse de dépôt qui est
sans doute celle de guetta en matière de
livrer à augmenter les taux actuellement
au mieux si on garde le livret à 2,25
vous sortirez pas moins de quatre vous
aurez au moins 100 points de base du
risque parce que vous allez ramasser
guemo vérifie si vous devenez un
établissement de crédit autrement dit
est-ce que vous avez une préoccupation
pour sortir à des taux bas et un dernier
point acquis active votre conseil rendra
compte de sa gestion chaque année merci
monsieur korman oh oui
l'objectif affiché par le gouvernement
c'est de participer à la
réindustrialisation du pays en à gourdon
en accordant des prêts aux pme mais je
voudrais revenir sur le point par
rapport aux retombées sur l'emploi par
rapport à la capacité d'engagement qui
est autour de 40 milliards sous forme de
prêts vu le besoin d'un point des pme
qui tourne autour de 200 milliards
qu'est ce que vous dites à ceux qui
disent que ce n'est pas assez
je m'excuse et j'étais j'allais poser
quasiment la même question que marcel
deneux moi j'ai bien compris que la bpi
elle présentait un intérêt c'était
formalisé c'était simplifiez vous
l'avais dit je reprends vos propos il
mangea que j'adhère complètement à cela
et c'était donner de la lisibilité
ceci étant dirais donc ce sera a priori
statut bancaire
donc a priori bâle iii va s'appliquer
c'est ce que vous nous avez dit et ma
question c'est où est le curseur entre
sécurité et efficacité parce que je
pense que c'est une vraie problématique
que vous allez rencontrer évidemment
compte tenu des deux l'objet même reste
de la bpi
donc je fais un peu plus court
commercial mais j'ai revu de poser la
question madame bourget merci monsieur
le président ma question va être un peu
malicieuse par rapport à au sérieux de
tout ce qui a été posé mais je crois
qu'elle mérite d'être posée je me suis
pris à rêver lorsque vous avez prononcé
monsieur juillet le mot de parité mais
c'était parité actionnariale j'aimerais
savoir si on respectera dans la
gouvernance de la v pays
la parité ou du moins on tendra à la
parité comme la loi le suggère mêmes
l'imposent et qu'on ne vivra pas la même
lui-même désagréments de la bce qui ne
compte pas une seule femme monsieur le
directeur général bien alors on va
répondre beaucoup je sais que ceux de
nice à un impératif et j'ai pas répondu
à une de ces à une de ses questions sur
l'économie sociale et solidaire savoir
que le principal intervenant ce domaine
monsieur sénateurs c'est le lait la
caisse des dépôts et qu'on mène d accord
innovant avec les associations que vous
avez un indiqué tout à l'heure
gouvernement a affiché son ambition pour
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans la
bpi
il ya 500 millions d'euros qui ont été
affichées eh bien nous nous mettrons en
oeuvre le cette ambition en faisant en
sorte là aussi d'apporter tout contre
expertise d
qui est aujourd'hui dans la caisse des
dépôts à la banque publique
d'investissement et les outils dont nous
disposons
notamment à travers les directions
régionales sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire on mettra en commun la sacem je
réponds tout à l'heure c'est une de
simplification de l'ue lisibilité et et
ça me paraît mieux mieux aller sur pour
répondre à monsieur marc haas il est
clair que la spécificité outre mer sera
prise en compte sur une déclinaison pour
les partenaires territoire telle qu'elle
a été indiqué par le ministre mais moi
je ne peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui
dans les départements je ne suis pas
assez avancée savoir combien comment et
tout cela il faut qu'à attendre quelques
temps m'enfin ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que cette spécificité sera bien
évidemment prise en compte dans le cadre
de la bpi pour répondre à monsieur mort
est ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il y ait
sur le numérique le lot le plus
important une fois que le gouvernement
rend février prochain défini ses
orientations sur sur la baie pis je
laisserais doit de répondre sur le le
rôle de la pe qui sera présent également
dans le cadre du conseil
d'administration pour monsieur bérit
débat oui nous souhaitons tous être plus
proche du terrain je crois que c'est
extrêmement important
je le redis je souhaite qu'il y ait
l'association la plus étroite et
l'implication des élus la plus forte
possible
il faut par rapport aux autres
interventions notamment par rapport à ce
qu'a dit monsieur dubois ce par rapport
à ce qu'a indiqué monsieur de noeuds il
faut pas il faut qu'on ait sécurité et
et une certaine flexibilité sur le
terrain et que nous nous ni nous
restions une banque de proximité mais
une banque de proximité qui soit visée
sur et qui permet de concilier d
approche défensive et offensive sur le
terrain c'est ce que je pense que c'est
équilibré pas si je vous dis
j'ai vu deux régions n'ont pas
heureusement les pays de la loire mais
j'ai vu d'autres régions la semaine
dernière où tout ça me paraît possible
c'est quelque chose où vous avez élu ça
a été bien dit par monsieur guillaume
vous avez élu caisse des dépôts oseo
tout ça arrive à travailler ensemble et
on doit pouvoir faire ce mouvement de
guichet unique en associant chacun d d d
d d d d d d d responsable et en évitant
ce que le le risque que pointait
monsieur deneux de faire en sorte qu'il
y ait des critiques de politisation
moi je crois que par rapport à ce qu'a
indiqué monsieur de ne s'est
c'est pas parce qu'elle est publique que
c'est une banque qui est risqué ou
qu'ils ne risquent rien apporté ça alors
là je m'élève vraiment vigoureusement
contre cela pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'on a retenu les leçons
du passé que deuxièmement nous séparons
là l'investissement du financement et
qu'il y à bien depuis acquis sont
différentes et que nous avons par
rapport à l'eau aux années qui ont
précédé la crise et ça a été dit tout à
l'heure un modèle prudentielles qui est
beaucoup plus rigoureux et un modèle et
c'est pour ça que je les nous l'avons
dit avec antoine gosset grainville dans
notre introduction le modèle
prudentielles il va s'appliquer de
manière différenciée aux prêts et aux
interventions en capital et on gardera
le modèle de spécificités pour pour vous
dire monsieur de ne la caisse des dépôts
c'est bien un établissement qui est
public depuis 1816 depuis la la la la la
restauration que je sache elle n'a
jamais fait défaut c'est le meilleur
tiers de confiance du pays
quant aux prêts que vous avez indiqué à
quel niveau sortira le sien que la
caisse des dépôts compte tenu des
ressources plus importantes qui lui sont
données et près par rapport aux
collectivités locales par rapport au pm
a accordé des prêts à des taux plus
faible que ce que vous avez indiquée
après nous dépendons des relations
notamment sur les fonds des pagnes des
accords que nous avons avec le trésor
administration que j'ai un peu connu par
le passé
donc voila mais la caisse est prête à
sortir à des taux plus bas que ce que
vous avez indiquée nous nous attendons
aussi des décines qui nous soit donné et
nous avons un effet de levier important
un effet levé d'entraînement parce que
vous dites c'est pas beaucoup mais c'est
un effet que je crois très important il
suffit de voir le nombre de personnes
qui viennent nous voir ou d'entreprises
qui viennent nous voir où monsieur re
serre en ville ou même ou dans le cas à
paris ou dans les déplacements région
parce que nous qu investisseur
parce que nous cofinance on parce que
nous savons mobiliser l'argent privé
et c'est en cela que la banque publique
d'investissement va permettre de jouer
de même il y aura des garanties et que
les garanties que l'on pourra donner
auront un effet d'amplification sur le
financement de l'économie
voilà ce que je voulais nick est pour
mais un bourget alors là moi je suis
très favorable
un bon 16 je suis très favorable à la
parité d'un d'un non non non je sais
bien que c'est babu venons mais je vous
réponde là aussi clairement comme je lé
fais monsieur vaugrenard suis très
favorable effectivement à ce que le lot
longtemps dans la gouvernance de la bpi
à des niveaux de parité dans les
conseils d'orientation et dans les
conseils d'administration et c'est pas à
moi de le décider mais je suis
extrêmement favorable pour être très
clair avec vous madame qu'il y ait
également parité dans la représentation
des présidents de régions au sein du
conseil d'administration de la banque
publique d'investissement avec moi qui
ai une femme qui est une femme
présidente de région qu'ils soient
membres du conseil d'administration de
la bpi pour être encore plus qu'elle
n'ira parfaitement
avec les reçoit alors j'étais quand même
je vais les échos même antoine sur les
sujets le plus facile sur la pub pour
répondre à monsieur morel vous avez
peut-être des noms d'ailleurs sur le
directeur général je pourrais vous les
donner à nos cieux cornado peut-être sur
le donc sur la question relative à la pe
en réalité la constitution de la bpi
c'est une décision qui amène à la fois
la caisse des dépôts et l'état et en
l'occurrence l'appel à transférer à
mettre en commun une partie
significative de leurs actifs pour notre
part c'est 50 % de nos fonds propres qui
vont être logés dans la bpi pour la pe
céder des actifs très significatif qui
seront transférées donc je ne peux pas
vous répondre
en réalité c'est déjà une opération de
transfert succès
et pour prolonger d'une phrase la
réponse de jean pierre jouyet sur les
règles prudentielles
concrètement donc ce que cela veut dire
c'est que la bpi sera soumise à bâle iii
et à bâle iii renforcée pour ce qui
concerne ses activités d'investissement
puisque comme elle investira beaucoup
dans des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire des pme qui sont des
investissements par nature risquée
il faut que les règles prudentielles qui
ce qui s'appliqueront soit adaptée à la
réalité et à l'ampleur des risques en
cause
de la guadeloupe c'est répondu merci
bien mes chers collègues je pense qu'on
aura beaucoup de travail lors du débat
parlementaire sur le rôle en particulier
du national du régional un problème est
aussi de l'état stratège et des
l'interventions donc filière et c'est au
niveau national et l'intervention au
niveau des pme t y es tu sais ces deux
choses qui vont se croiser merci
beaucoup en tous les cas messieurs les
directeurs d'avoir participé je suis
persuadé que nous ont peut-être
l'occasion de nous revoir
lors du débat parlementaire oui quand
les choses raffiné passé au premier
filtre de l'assemblée s'est pas répondu
à une question je suis juste dernier
point pas s'il vous plaît cornano
l'avait posé ça a été posée juste sur un
dernier point il est évident que le
conseil de la bpi et que la gouvernance
de la bp devra rendre compte
annuellement de ses activités comme le
fait la caisse des dépôts moi j'ai tu
combats au parlement et que donc vous
ayez un compte rendu d'activités de la
bpi devant le parlement à chaque fois
sur les activités de la bpi pour
répondre à la question qui m'a été posée
voilà
le plus dur c'était la barrière dans la
tête est-ce que moi à 6 23 ans val
fourré j'étais capable de passer à la
une société ne peut pas se construire
sur ce qu'elle n'est plus vrai que c'est
la fierté de saisir on a été un peu plus
loin que nos parents qui ont pas
forcément eu la chance d'aller d'aller
aussi loin par exemple un phénomène
général c'est réussite sociale
la question n'est pas de savoir si la
discrimination elle existe elle existe
c'est clair la vraie question c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'elle va t'empêcher de
devenir ce que tu veux être la société
égalitaire n'a jamais existé que dans
des lits